santé avec cette campagne qui commence
aujourd'hui sur les chaînes de télé pour
une meilleure nutrition méfiez vous des
produits gras et sucrés
un cocktail détonnant 19 % des enfants
souffrent de surpoids nathalie sapina
nous ne sommes jamais très loin des
solutions qui permettent de limiter
notre consommation de produits sucrés et
gras - de crème dessert - de biscuits et
de sodas voilà ce que préconise ce spot
du ministère de la santé
ambition contrebalancer le matraquage
publicitaire des fabricants de produits
gras et sucrés et promouvoir une
alimentation saine c'est une première on
peut très bien manger se faire plaisir
et manger de religieuse au chocolat si
on en a envie
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que ça peut
faire ça de temps en temps et que
souvent plutôt que dans vos produits
sucrés et gras on peut le substituer par
un fouet ou un produit lacté qui va dans
le sens des objectifs de la qualité de
la santé
riposte immédiate des producteurs de
sucre
avec cette campagne presse qui
s'inquiète d'un monde où le sucre serait
bannie pourtant ils se cachent partout
même dans les produits salés même dans
les eau minérale aromatisée dont
certaines contiennent jusqu'à quinze
morceaux de sucre un piège en habitude
les enfants à une consommation de sucre
on peut s'en dispenser et il faut se
limiter à l'eau tout simplement
en moyenne les enfants un gears gîte 100
g de sucres rapides par jour ces deux
fois trop conséquence obésité mais aussi
maladies cardiovasculaires diabète
cancer à entendre les maires
l'information commence à faire son
chemin
elle est très très très sucré
on est quand même une maman on a un
coeur on lâche même on essaye quand même
de gérer on dit non une fois par jour ça
suffit cette campagne peut-elle modifier
les mauvaises habitudes avec
l'interdiction des distributeurs
automatiques dans les lycées et collèges
l'objectif du gouvernement est ambitieux
faire baisser de 25 % la consommation de
sucres rapides